et donnons du travail enfin prenons les
CV acceptons les donnons l'heure du
travail et galère rompu dans les halls
parce qu'il faut se lever le lendemain
matin
en tant que jeune
issu de la banlieue on faisait pas
beaucoup entendu vous exprimer sur le
problème
si vous aviez du brûler des voitures
vous auriez brûlé quel modèle de voiture
j'aimerais celle de ma mère ah moi
j'aurais brûlé une Multipla après moche
et je pense que même ordre
les multiples un dauphin là avec trois
places deviné par un stagiaire
d'été
très bien
le multiple moi j'en ai eu au tournais
elle est moche mais on est bien dedans
et c'est comme ma femme
ma belle
c'est trop grand
[Rires]
vous êtes déçu que Sarkozy alpin aux
Antilles ben ouais parce qu'il serait
plus bronzé et du coup plus présentable
plus présidentiable quasiment regardez
de Villepin est super bronzée
moi non mais même si je suis pas
d'accord tu passes moi je trouve mais
c'est vrai quoi
c'est la classe on va avoir la classe
président français
pourtant c'est le plus aimé mais c'est
pas le plus élu c'est ça le problème
c'est que il faut absolument pas que tu
es comédien ou que tu es un mec de cœur
il faut absolument pas aimer Sarkozy ça
ça me gonfle terriblement moi je
l'aimerai bien rien que pour ça comme
par exemple tu vois les artistes sont à
gauche
à 80 % parce que c'est pas bien de
d'être à droite toi moi je considère la
gauche à droite comme papa et maman qui
tu préfères papa ou maman j'aime bien
maman parce que elle fait des caresses
elle fait des trucs puis des fois papa
il tape un peu sur la table pour faire
le truc donc tu préfères qui papa ou
maman bah c'est bien que ça soit un coup
papa un coup maman moi sans être artiste
j’excède Sarkozy ah ouais vraiment
moi je donne le mot est un peu fort
[Applaudissements]
vis-à-vis de Sarkozy malgré tout enfin
c'est pas de l'anti sarkozyme qu'on fait
mon essaie de regarder ce qu'il fait
depuis 2 ans et effectivement ça va pas
dans le sens de l'intégration pour les
jeunes de banlieue ça va plus dans le
sens de la répression quoi et c'est pas
parce que je suis artiste que je dis ça
je vois juste que il y a plein de
budgets qui étaient alloués à d'autres
choses que la répression dans les
banlieues qui qui sont plus là et je
connais pas mal la banlieue en fait et
je vois que ça se les conditions se
détériorent et que c'est aussi par
rapport à une politique qui est menée et
je
il se trouve que c'est Sarkozy quand
même qui est la tête de proue de cette
politique et donc le mieux le mieux
c'est surtout pas un seul flic en banlie
c'est parce que je dis mais je pense que
c'est exactement ça que tu es une gamine
que tu as du mal à lui vous voyez
prendre une baguette de pain comme moi
dans des endroits où j'ai habité tu te
dis elle va traverser la place il s'est
passé elle va revenir tu dis il faut je
pense que c'est pas tout rien par
exemple je pense que c'est pas tout
répressif ou tout juste sympa que sympa
bien sûr et par exemple moi c'est pour
ça que je dis je le répète par exemple
de responsabiliser les parents pour
qu'il s'occupe de leurs enfants je pense
pas que ça soit fasciste c'est comme ça
la loi le dit comme ça les parents sont
propriétaires coréennes de leurs enfants
si un pitbull bouffe la gueule d'une
petite fille on va condamner le
propriétaire du du Jean-Marie excuse-moi
ça c'est tout à fait logique tout le
monde le comprend non non
parler depuis tout à l'heure et
j'entends les mots comme police pitbull
shit et il est là le problème
sans action positives et s'il y en a
trois mauvaises c'est les trois sur
lesquels on va mettre le premier j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure il y avait il y
avait des associations dans les
banlieues qui étaient subventionnés qui
envoyaient les jeunes en vacances ou qui
les envoyaient dans des familles
d'accueils et les budgets ont sauté ces
gamins là qu'est-ce qu'ils font le
mercredi après-midi ils galèrent dans
les halls qu'est-ce qu'on vient de leur
interdire
donc où il est leur espace de liberté
c'est à dire que on leur enlève les
petits les petits cadeaux les petits
bonbons et ensuite on leur enlève les
endroits où ils peuvent au moins se voir
discuter quoi juste un espace privilégié
pour pour se rencontrer
évidemment des problèmes dans les hall
il y a des gens qui arrivent pas à
dormir parce que les gamins ils parlent
dans les halls jusqu'à minuit 1h du mat
mais c'est pas la majorité des halls de
banlieues sauf que c'est ce que c'est le
discours de Sarkozy ça veut dire tous
les gamins maintenant sont dans les
halls et font du bruit les gens
responsables n'arrivent pas à dormir
donc interdisons les halls aux jeunes
du travail enfin prenons les CV
acceptons les donnons l'heure du travail
et galère rompu dans les halls parce
qu'il faut se lever le lendemain matin
voilà
alors
je pense que c'est comme ça
et tout à l'heure j'ai entendu aussi
j'aurais quand même Président
je sais pas si vous le faites dans votre
rue mais moi dans ma rue il y a pas un
mec qui traîne par terre que je ne vais
pas voir et à qui je demande qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour lui et de quoi il
a besoin alors
c'est ce que chacun d'entre nous devrait
faire mais seulement quand tu as un pays
tout entier à t'occuper c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
mais on les a mis vachement de côté ça
fait quand même c'est le problème il est
pas d'aujourd'hui ça fait des années que
c'est comme ça ça a déjà sauté avant et
en cas il y a eu des émeutes qui sont
pas l'équivalent de ça et Mitterrand est
venu il me semble dans les cités il
avait fait un voyage c'était des 4000 ou
ça la Courneuve à La Courneuve il est
allé et il a dit ouais ça on va raser ça
on va raser ça on va raser ça va changer
vous avez les caméras c'était il y a 20
ans et elles sont restées et je pense
que les faits Zidane a fait que tout ça
ça a pu engrainer encore un petit peu
parce qu'en 98 on se dit ah ben c'est
bon on marque des buts donc c'est génial
Zidane président donc les Arabes ça va
tout va bien les mecs de cité ça va ils
s'en sortent et en fait ça a permis mais
sinon les émeutes elles auraient dû
exploser il y a encore il y a 6 ans de
ça normalement il y a autre chose que
que j'ai entendu que il y a des jeunes
qui ont le choix entre vendre du shit ou
bien aller travailler et il y en a qui
préfèrent les vendre du shit et alors ça
vraiment non ça vraiment non parce que
ceux qui malheureusement
c'est un vrai c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai un mec ou deux qui vont vendre mais
c'est pas genre 55 ans
la question est posée que à un moment
donné le jeune qui est dans dans on va
effectivement lui faire cette
proposition et si jamais il l'accepte et
ben il va après avoir du mal à aller
gratter mais la première proposition
Jean-Marie la première proposition
excuse-moi de te couper elle vient quand
même du jeune qui envoie son CV et qu'on
lui dit non donc la proposition après du
dealer de shit elle vient après et je
veux finir sur la dernière chose
la meilleure solution et ce qu'il faut
faire à partir de maintenant c'est faux
qu'on aille voter il faut qu'on aille
tous voter et que ça sera le meilleur
moyen pour avoir des gens qui nous
représenteront et se faire écouter il
faut aller voter OK
retour Amélie on est d'accord si on peut
faire quelque chose ici pour que les
jeunes s'inscrivent pour 2007 moi je
pense que que chacun d'entre nous
devrait essayer de s'occuper de son
prochain et si il y en a seulement deux
ou trois paru et ben on règle vraiment
beaucoup de problèmes donc tu t'occupes
de ton voisin et ben tu fais tout
simplement pas 15000 morts de la
solitude pas mort de la canicule on
s'est gouré ils sont pas mort de la
canicule les vieux sont morts de la
solitude parce que leurs voisins de
palier de s'occupaient pas de la vieille
personne qui était à côté de bien
évidemment si évidemment mais
non mais c'est sûr
qu'ils sont vraiment détruits en bas de
chez toi tu mépriserais un mec comme
Sarkozy par exemple parce que c'est
c'est il est merci parce que si un mec
ou n'importe quoi vous vous gueulez
après quelqu'un qui
maintenant on gagne sur un mec on gueule
sur un mec qui donc a coupé les budgets
pour aider toutes les problèmes de
quartier comme Eric en a parlé tout à
l'heure mais c'est le même mec qui fait
des qui fait des lois pour pour alléger
le l'impôt sur la grosse fortune
l'impôt sur la grosse fortune dedans
aujourd'hui
sur chez nous sur ce qui se passe chez
nous et autre chose sur les parents pour
pas blâmer les parents non excuse-moi
mais de blâmer les parents et leur dire
ce sont les parents qui sont
responsables je trouve ça scandaleux
c'est une petite fille qui est dehors
maman qui a quelqu'un j'ai une maman qui
a 80 ans si j'étais encore au quartier
aujourd'hui c'est pas elle qui me
bloquerait pour sortir
quasiment pas français il y en a 80 ans
je vois pas pourquoi elle va m'empêchera
pas sortir à 2h je suis pas de la
génération je suis pas de la génération
de mes parents aujourd'hui et je suis
sorti du quartier je suis sorti du
quartier mais tu vas dans les quartiers
par leurs parents le problème quand même
vient de là la racine d'un problème
vient de ces mecs qu'on construit ces
espèces d'imondies d'horreur totale de
monstrueux qui se dégrade
c'est le problème c'est que simplement
quand tu as des espèces de trucs qui se
dégradent l'ascenseur qui tombe en panne
les adresses il y a pas de boulot 55 ans
donc là c'est pas les parents qu'on
espère que 50 ans
il est là aussi le problème allons tous
voter non mais par contre votre discours
il est il est il englobe absolument tout
alors que ça n'est pas vrai qu'est-ce
qui n'est pas vrai c'est-à-dire que il y
a une partie comme par exemple en Corse
si tu me dis que tous les corps sont des
non mais par contre il y a des
tueurs qui ne veulent que tuer qui sont
des
aussi c'est pour ça qu'il faut respecter
par exemple ils sont pas tous vendeurs
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu